all right the great male invalid
conundrum uh
we've already told you that better than
four and a half million ballots have
already uh been filed um
it was only around 75 000 at this time
four years ago can you imagine how
overwhelming that is so overwhelming
um that we're getting news out of ohio
and this is something that the president
just retweeted
nearly 50 000 voters received the wrong
ballots
in ohio again raising questions as to
how how safe the process is how reliable
it
is uh governor mike dewine of ohio with
us right now governor good to have
you good morning to you hope you're
doing well
on this 50 000 ballot uh thing what
happened do you know
no this is franklin county i think they
said they had a vendor who made a
mistake and
you know to make sure the way at least i
understand it
um you had some people in a part of
franklin county
that got the wrong local names um
and in state legislative races it would
not have
they obviously of course had the
president on there and they had the
and joe biden on there so it wouldn't
have impacted
the you know the presidential but
somebody caught it right away former
state legislature
actually caught it and uh you know
they're they're correcting it so
look mistakes can happen we don't like
it uh no one likes to see it but
we've got a red-hot race in ohio
uh i think the president's going to win
in ohio
but ohio is as you know a swing state
and it's going to go right down to the
wire it's
you know we have very expansive voting
in ohio uh people can go into
and vote at the board of elections um
any of the 88 counties where they live
they can go into that local board of
elections
up you know four weeks going into the
election
they can do you know the absentee ballot
uh or they certainly can wait till
election day which is what fran and i
usually do and go in
you have 13 hours to to vote
um you know we're talking about how
mail-in ballots have become so
overwhelmingly popular right now
again we're at four and a half million
now it might be even more than that now
governor i don't know
but it's running out of pace that just
dwarfs the 75 000 or so we had four
years ago at this time
the president's argument has been that
that that's
that's overwhelming and right for your
abuse i i know you're trying to assure
folks that in ohio that won't be the
case
this was an issue maybe in franklin
county and hopefully isolated to that
it's been corrected
but do you blame him for being concerned
a lot of people are getting increasingly
concerned
this kind of stuff just keeps happening
yeah i mean i think if anybody is
concerned
they can go in and vote they can go in
and vote uh any day of the week
basically um uh monday through friday i
believe
initially and then later on it goes into
the weekend so you go to your board of
elections
monday and you can go vote if you want
to want to do that and we saw
tuesday was the first day that you could
vote we saw lines up
outside of boards of elections
so people have the option to do that if
they don't want to deal with people at
all
you know they can do it absentee or they
can wait
uh you know and do it on doing on
election day which is where everyone
used to
do it in ohio it looks like we're
we've doubled the number of these
absentee ballots
than what we had four years ago at this
time that's what the secretary of
state's office says
you know governor you had a scare a
while back where you had briefly tested
positive for the coronavirus turns out
um that it may have been a false
positive you ultimately tested negative
i hope that's still the case and you're
healthy and well
it is but it gave you that's i'm very
happy to hear that governor then
you know all the dust up over the
president's conditions some people are
worried that
a little more than a week after being
you know in the hospital walter reed and
uh
close to two weeks since his diagnosis
that now is not the time to be having
campaign events
even properly distanced uh for the
truman balcony
at the white house the worry gets to be
monday in florida
and just resuming his activities um what
do you think of all that
well you know i think campaign needs to
continue
the president needs to be able to get
his message out
to the people of the country and the
people of the key states
my position has not changed you know
large gatherings are not safe when
people don't social distance and when
they don't wear a mask
so you know we would say the same thing
about any
political campaign we said the same
thing about demonstrators earlier on
we just asked people you know where
where mass keep the social distance
um i believe uh neil we can really
do two things at once that we can live
our lives
at the same time be cautious and prudent
about what we do in regard to try to
keep the spread down
and so you know my ideas are my position
has not changed it's based on the
science keep distance
but we can't just you know cower in our
in our
bedrooms and and not go out i mean we've
opened
you know we have school open in ohio um
people are making their own personal
decisions whether
the school is remote or whether the
school is open five days a week these
decisions are made made by the local
school districts
our restaurants are open our bars they
have some limitation on the hours
but everything else is open so we
encourage people to go about your lives
we also encourage them just to be
careful and that would be the same thing
with
a political rally that's well put
governor continued good health best of
luck to you uh
governor dewine the beautiful state of
ohio a battleground to put it mildly and
joe biden and donald trump are separated
just by a tick or two there in there i
said so it still
remains a battleground